- I know what's happening here.
My mom called up Buzzfeed
and told everyone to
say nice things to me.
Right?
- So here's how it's going to work.
I'm going to go and give
the first compliment,
and then that person is going to go
and give somebody else a compliment.
It's going to be a compliment chain.
I actually want to tell you
that I think you're great.
You have such positive, beautiful energy.
No, and I love your work and what you do,
and how you make people
feel special in the office.
- Thank you so much!
- So here's the thing,
you're going to have to go
and compliment somebody else.
So who do you want to compliment?
- I want to compliment Steph.
You just started working here,
and you've been like, guns blazing,
working hard and--
- Stop! (laughs)
- motivated, with a
really positive attitude,
and a non-stop smile.
- Can we hug?
- We can hug.
- Oh, Ricky!
I just wanted to let you
know how great you are,
and I hope your greatness rubs off on me.
- Aww. That's so cool.
- I actually rubbed myself with that.
- You are such a kind and caring person.
(laughs)
When we were both interns
you sat across from me,
and answered any questions that I had,
and you were really helpful.
I'm very glad that we're friends.
- Aww, Ken. That is so nice!
I think you work really hard.
- Oh thank you.
- And I think you put everything you have,
into all the work you do.
I just really wanted to
applaud you for that.
- Thank you.
- I appreciate you and
I'm glad you're here.
- I wanted to thank you for
being such an amazing person.
You always help me when I need
help with a bunch of shit,
and I just wanted to say
you're a very sweet man,
and you're very beautiful
and you're very nice.
- Hey Shane.
- Hey.
- You're beautiful and thank you.
I just want to thank you for being you.
Just give me a hug.
- I thought of someone
I wanted to compliment,
and I want to compliment you.
- Thank you.
- I'm always thankful for your positivity.
You're one of my favorite
people around this office.
I just wanted to tell you that.
- Thank you. I feel
the same way about you.
- Give a little hug.
- I wanted to say that,
thank you so much for being my friend.
You inspire me everyday.
- Oh my god.
Now I feel really happy and warm.
You're the best, Chris.
- Thanks.
(light music)